if you've ever watched showtime's comedy
drama series shameless you know the
gallagher's lives are far from ordinary
each character tends to end up in some
unfortunate situation that takes an
entire village to correct whether it's
carl selling guns at school fiona
hitting her mother's corpse before her
funeral or frank losing his son in a bet
taking an alzheimer's patient hostage or
intentionally killing a woman with a
heart condition shameless is filled with
controversial content many viewers
clearly found the jaw-dropping
activities depicted in shameless
entertaining as evidenced by the fact
that the show ran for 134 episodes
across 11 seasons before its finale in
april 2021. however plenty of fans
didn't love every episode some longtime
viewers found certain story lines
absolutely disgusting and many more have
said that the show crossed the line on a
number of occasions examples of
shameless moments that left viewers
uneasy and even outraged include
veronica convincing her mother to sleep
with her boyfriend so she could have a
child for them and frank making his own
son carl believe that he has cancer of
course there are many more over-the-top
shameless moments that we won't get into
here
debbie stole a baby we have to figure
out how to return it but many fans
believe one scene in the season 4
episode there's the rub went way too far
in the episode it's fiona's birthday
which should be a joyous celebration
however this is fiona gallagher we're
talking about so there's bound to be
some drama involved her boyfriend mike
ends up dumping her because she's having
an affair with his brother robbie the
everyday chaos of a shameless episode
ensues including fights drinking and
partying towards the end of the episode
robbie gives fiona a birthday present a
little bag of drugs fiona kicks robbie
out but leaves the bag on the table she
eventually shares the drugs during her
party unfortunately the youngest
gallagher brother liam finds the drugs
and ingests some debbie finds liam
unconscious in the other room and calls
fiona for help but it seems like it's
too late the young boy is passed out
with white powder all over his face the
paramedics are called and fiona is
arrested for child abuse and possession
of an illegal substance liam ends up
recovering from the overdose but doctors
warn he may experience learning
disabilities moving forward although
this kind of thing isn't completely
unexpected in the series it still
doesn't make it any easier to witness
many viewers felt that this depiction of
child abuse and endangerment was too
much even for a show like shameless
fiona's mistakes didn't start at
disrespecting her dead mother and stop
at endangering her little brother over
the course of the series 11 seasons nine
of which fiona actress emmy rossum
starred in she did a lot of questionable
things and fans had no problem airing
their grievances about the character one
reddit user admitted that he likes
shameless but finds the gallagher family
terrible particularly fiona for a number
of reasons the redditer wrote fiona is
ridiculous she's cheated on pretty much
all of her boyfriends and is controlling
of everyone around her the only thing
she did that could be considered good is
raising her siblings and even then she
has to lord it over anyone who will
listen and she never seems to show
remorse for what she does
i'm not
just chaos
another viewer and redditer pointed out
that when rossum left shameless it
brought fiona's core storyline to an end
at the perfect moment fiona left at the
right place and the right time in my
opinion her role as acting guardian was
more or less fulfilled by the time she
asks ian for permission to leave it's
strikingly obvious that she is no longer
needed not all shameless fans feel this
way of course even in the face of all
fiona has done wrong plenty of viewers
still think she deserves a lot of credit
for doing all she could to take care of
her family one redditor wrote fiona gets
so much but i think she is one of the
best characters in the show she's got
the most empathy out of all the
gallaghers for her family and will do
anything to help them whenever they need
it she deserves the world despite her
awful mistakes with her significant
others and liam check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about shameless are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]